[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you, Judith.
I feel like you
could do the talk,
as you know so well the work.
Well, thank you.
I'm very happy to be here
among such great Fellows.
And thank you to the Radcliffe
Institute and the team.
I would like also to thank
Meg Rotzel and [INAUDIBLE]
for the shows that
you will see later.
And I would also like to thank
Julia Sweeney, my research
partner, who has done a
great job on that talk
but also researching for my
current project at Radcliffe.
So I'm not a good
improviser, so I will read.
I'm sorry for that.
In the late '90s,
in the aftermath
of what was commonly called
the Civil War, which was not
just civil, but involved many
regional and international
actors, I had the urge
to express and reflect
on what had happened,
which led me
to make artworks
dealing primarily
with the question of
history and its narration.
What image of these dramatic
events could I retain?
What image of them
would I recreate?
At that time, I
found myself caught
in the tension between the
temptation, even the necessity,
of recounting our history and
the impossibility of fully
accessing it.
Some facts, dramas
and experiences
are bound to never reach us and
will remain unspoken, buried.
We can never certify
their existence,
but only presume it with
traces in their absence.
The act of witnessing, the
notion of responsibility,
the mechanisms of
memory and the use
of the archive
and oral histories
were all crucial elements
to me from early on.
It is within that
framework that I initiated
assembling a series
of testimonies
on the Lebanese wars for
my work, Objects of War,
and later for Here
and Perhaps Elsewhere.
In Objects of War, I asked
several, various people
actually, to choose an
ordinary and unusual object
from the time of the wars that
served as a starting point
for narrating a personal,
lived experience.
While ostensibly creating a
collective memory of the wars,
the testimonies gathered
in Objects of War exposed
the vanity of such a task.
It became clear to
me that the only way
to approach with presenting
and narrating the Lebanese wars
at that moment was
to abandon the quest
for a complete narrative
or an absolute truth.
I could only propose
attempts, fragments
of chronicles, relative
truth and first person
accounts of the extraordinary
and the banal, all of which
underline the gaps and losses
in history and in the process
of remembering.
Objects of War is not a film.
It is shown only
as an installation,
including both the
video testimonies
and the original objects
that are displayed as relics,
as you saw.
As an ongoing project,
Objects of War
has evolved into
an open archive.
And here you can see some of
the objects that are various.
As of today there are
six Objects of War.
They each run for approximately
an hour to an hour and a half.
So of course, it's not
expected from the audience
to watch all of them when
you come to the show.
But it gives you a sense
at once of the intimacy,
but also of the very personal,
yet universal, accounts.
I will show you a short excerpt.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- There's no beginning nor end
and no hierarchy or chronology
among the various
stories recounted.
In both Objects of War and
Here and Perhaps Elsewhere,
the fragments of history
are memory and oblivion
at the same time.
Parts of an incomplete
whole, when assembled,
rearranged and reinterpreted,
they border fiction.
Through Here and
Perhaps Elsewhere,
I tried to regain an image of
Beirut that had been fragmented
in my mind for so many years.
Could the fragmentation
of the city only
be captured and expressed
by a fragmented image?
Knowing that thousands
disappeared during the Lebanese
wars-- actually we
say around 17,000--
and that in most cases,
the circumstances
of their disappearance
were never known,
I traversed the
former green line,
the area that divided
Beirut into East and West
and the common sight
of kidnappings,
and asked people I encountered
if they knew someone
who had been kidnapped here.
I filmed for three weeks,
punctuating my journey
with stops at the sites
of former checkpoints,
relying on archival
photographs in an attempt
to pinpoint their location
within the present.
And here you can see
an example of some
of these archival photographs.
At times, people
faced difficulty
finding the exact location
of the checkpoints
within the cityscape.
And when they did locate
them, often their location
did not match that of
the archival photograph.
Using documentary tactics, Here
and Perhaps Elsewhere charts
a personal map of a real space
to comprehend its realities,
constructing your subjective
geography of space.
In this work, the
place designated
as a green line or
dividing line is
central as an image and symbol.
Yet it is never defined and
fails to be represented.
One could say that,
although the dividing line
physically exists, it became
over time a mental line that
fragmented the city and
undermined coexistence
in many of its areas.
In almost every
street I walked, it
seemed someone had
experienced a loss.
And even though we were in
2002, the lingering presence
of the war appeared in most
of the stories recounted.
I filmed without preparation,
recording the speech triggered
by my question, registering
the mechanisms of recollection,
reenactment and narration
in all their manifestations,
from what people
could or could not
remember to what they refused
to tell me or feared to say.
And I must say here that had
I done this film today exactly
in the same manner, it would
not be the same speeches
that I would collect.
Because the political
situation has changed.
So in that sense,
it is also really
a diagnosis of the present.
So the performance
of memory here
allowed me for the activation
of the past remnants
within the present.
Its inclination toward
omission and distortion
and the discrepancy between
what is brought to memory
and what is documented
interrogates a very idea
of truth.
I'll show you a
four minute excerpt.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[STREET NOISE]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
- Although the recorded
accounts of personal experiences
in both Objects of War
and Here and Perhaps
Elsewhere could
act as documents,
the awareness of the participant
of being filmed, as well
as the subjectivity
of my selection
and assemblage of
testimonies leave
room for a fictional dimension.
I also wrote a short
fiction by the same name
about the disappearance
of a man recounted
in five different versions
by each protagonist.
It was published as
a booklet in 2003
and later as a website in 2009.
I won't have time to talk about
it, so if you would like to,
you can visit this website.
It's a website of
this short story.
Disappearance as
well as the questions
of truth and
responsibility are also
at The Heart of the
Journey, a video essay
which uncovers a suppressed
narrative within my own family,
the story of my
grandmother Rose, located
at the intersection of the
personal and collective.
The Journey
simultaneously reflects
on the conflicts in our
region and questions
my own identity and
political choices.
Rose was born in Jerusalem
in 1910 and moved to Beirut
in the '30s.
Her character allows
me to create a link
to the complex history,
and I must say unresolved,
between the Palestinian
and Lebanese people.
In the film I look
back from what
seems like a hopeless present.
And I'm sure you can identify
to that now, that has inherited
a tumultuous and
fragmented [INAUDIBLE]
to a moment in our past when
peace, unity, and modernity
seemed like a promise
for our region.
Constructed like a spider
web, the scenes of The Journey
were not edited in
chronological time, but rather
according to elliptical
time and structure.
The disparate fragments are
assembled retrospectively,
emphasizing the erratic
rhythm of memory
and the incapacity of
linear historical narration
to account for the intricacies
of human experience.
I will show you an excerpt
which is a bit long,
but I feel it's--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ENGINE HUM]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
- Another central
element in The Journey
is loss, visible in
my grandmother's loss
of first her
homeland, Palestine,
and then her son, my uncle,
kidnapped during the war
and never returned.
To this day, we have no answers
regarding the true account
of his disappearance.
In the process of grappling
with losses for which there
are no reparations or recovery,
this train of memories
made palpable through
the work's reliance
on the mnemonic aid of
archival photographs and eight
millimeter films as well
as through the fragility
of spoken testimonies.
Especially evident in
language, slippage--
such as when my grandmother
slides in and out of awareness.
Ultimately, the third loss
experience in The Journey
is Rose's own suggested
death as her illness grows
and she begins losing
track with reality.
Until the 2006 war--
so I realized yesterday
that you may not
know what the 2006 war is.
In July 2006, Hezbollah,
who is the Party of God,
kidnapped two Israeli soldier
at the border of South Lebanon.
And following that,
Israel attacked Lebanon,
and there was a major
siege for one month.
And maybe there were 1,500
deaths and one million
displaced.
And the entire southern suburb,
as well as the southern part
of the country was destroyed.
So until the 2006
war, I had never
realized the work and the
immediacy of an event.
And I actually thought
that The Journey
would be my last work dealing
with the issue of war.
The series of eight prints
and the video Nights and Days
are part of a body of work
that relates to the 2006 war
in Lebanon, which raised
the following questions.
How are we to produce images of
artistic value in times of war,
in its immediacy,
versus producing them
with a distance on that event?
Can we testify while
still remaining
at a critical distance?
Nights and Days
question the relation
between the time of the
occurrence of an event
and the production of
documents on that event.
I was unable to produce
anything during the 2006 war.
But after 10 days, I started
taking notes, daily notes.
I wondered, if I document my
daily life during that period,
will I deprive myself from
the capacity and the necessity
to forget?
I considered these collected
elements as a trace
to be later reintroduced
in new narratives.
Only a few months
after did I feel
capable of using these notes
to construct a narrative that
conveys at once a
sense of urgency
and my incapacity of
representing this war.
The photographs-- so there
are eight photographs--
and the video are based on the
film and written notes made
that summer.
They interrogate the tension
between the desire to witness
and the desire to open a breach
in the capacity of witnessing,
to undermine it or
accept its failure.
The first part of the video
resembles a diary of war,
yet is not.
It alternates day
shots with night shots,
with my own voiceover
expressing the waiting,
the interrogations, and
the fears experienced
in such unusual time.
Now I will show you
an excerpt of one
minute of the first part.
- I cannot remember what I
was doing before it all began.
I do not fear anymore.
I wait.
I recall images of those
torn, battered figures.
I insert my face, my
body in their place.
Am I wounded or dead?
No, wounded.
I scream.
I do not want to have
both my legs amputated.
I howl.
I cry.
Nothing can be done.
They must amputate.
He had no face left to cry.
The bomb beheaded him.
I insert my body in his place.
I die.
And then the explosion--
I only faint in this version.
I do not die.
I recall the bodies,
the fragments
of bodies strewn around me.
I cannot feel anymore.
The pain is pure.
There must be pieces of my body
missing, pieces of my being
surely.
I do not recognize anyone.
Later--
- So the bomb is real, but
my narration is fictive.
Obviously it's a speculation.
It's an imagined narrative.
The second part
of Nights and Days
is a journey to South Lebanon,
which had just been devastated
during that war.
It alternates peaceful landscape
with ruins and destruction
with only music for
sound, as in my opinion
no words could express
this devastation.
So in the second part,
my voice withdraws,
replaced by a drone--
a sound piece composed by
Charbel Haber, with whom
I collaborate regularly--
based on the actual recording
of the Israeli drone.
As some may know, a drone
is not just a guided plane.
But it's also a music genre.
It starts from a
single note and extends
to become a musical piece.
And I'll show you--
um, a very short--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
- The experience of
living in Beirut today,
together with my desire to
explore new modes of narration,
has consequently led to
a shift in my approach
to image, speech and more
generally, to representation.
I continue to reflect
on Beirut's history
and its present, moving
away from an engagement
with direct speech and
the use of personal memory
to a more distant [INAUDIBLE]
mode of associating
various elements and traces
through space and time.
Evoking the idea
of a palimpsest,
my recent work Beirut,
Autopsy of a City
and my ongoing project
Under-Writing Beirut
shed light on layers
of temporal deposits
that are enmeshed in
an open-ended process
of absorption, erasier
and reconfiguration.
I woke up one day thinking that
the city I've been living in
could disappear.
That disappearance
is not exclusively
a historical process
or an extinct one.
This anxiety led me to create
Beirut, Autopsy of a City.
So it's quite an
irrational project.
The first chapter that you see
here, a history of Beirut's
possible disappearance,
juxtaposes and overlaps
collected elements
from past epochs
to re-examine notions
of chronology.
It retells the stories of
the conquests, defeats,
and natural disasters that
shaped and disfigured Beirut.
The viewer wanders amid
intertemporally connected
fragments that become
fictionalized chronicle.
So I used videos, text and
images from various sources.
These are examples of
the images contained
in that first chapter.
The second chapter,
"Beirut, 1,001 Views",
is a projection of
a panoramic view
of the city that is an
amalgam of photographs
taken at different
time in its history.
In a single scene, a ship
from the 19th century
floats in a photograph
of the sea from the '50s,
under a menacing
skyline from the '80s.
The resulting image is neither
past one nor a present one,
but effective representation
where some element does appear.
Within it, well other--
and here you cannot see, because
it's a 16 minute animation
which is deliberately naive.
But you will see elements
that appear and disappear
throughout those 16 minutes.
This third chapter,
"Beirut, 2058",
displaces the anxiety from
the past and its remnants
and project them onto a
speculative future, apocalyptic
realm.
Where the city has
vanished, leaving us
with one peaceful image of a
seashore under its quiet sky.
And this text is
the introduction
to that third chapter
is written by a narrator
at the first person.
We don't know if
this catastrophe
was a natural disaster
or caused by war.
And this is how it's
displayed [INAUDIBLE].
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[WATER RUSHING]
- While Beirut, Autopsy of
a City was about a specific
moment that endangered the life
of Beirut from 1200 BC until
2058 AD, Under-Writing
Beirut looks at historically
and personally significant
locations within
Beirut's present, investigating
their sociological,
political and economic history.
How can narratives emerge
from or be triggered by places
rather than represent them?
So here for me is quite an
important shift in my practice
and on the notion
of representation.
[END PLAYBACK]
The first chapter is "Mathaf",
the Arabic word for museum.
And the name of the area
where I live in Beirut.
Home to the National Museum
of Beirut opened in '42,
the museum is located along what
was once a green line, which
divided east and west Beirut.
Once a site meant to
represent national union,
the museum in this
area became a symbol
of the country's
division and the backdrop
for sectarian violence.
During the war and
despite preservation
efforts made by the
museum conservator
to protect the collection by
building walls and concealing
objects with concrete, as you
can see in that photograph,
these are sarcophagi that
are covered with concrete
to be protected from potential
looting or from militiamen.
The museum's building
was destroyed
and part of it's small
yet impressive collection
was severely damaged,
looted or lost.
Under-Writing Beirut--
Mathaf responds
both to the impossibility
I faced while attempting
to access artifacts from
the museum's storage
as well as its archives
and to the only objects
made available.
So this is a view of
the entire installation.
So the only object that
were made available to me
were this beautiful,
yet now damaged,
good shepherd mosaic and a
photograph documenting it
from the time of the wars when
a sniper punctured a hole in it
to have a strategic view onto
the immediate surroundings.
So the immediate
surroundings, like I said,
is a passage checkpoint
between east and west.
And you can see today, as it
was filled from the outside,
but the hole was kept
intact from the inside.
Object of War is a
negative of the sniper hole
cast as a concrete sculpture.
It's initial incentive
rests on the practice
of the imprint as a trace of
contact with a body or void.
Yet it is a free reformulation
rather than an exact replica.
And here you can
see the sketch--
the document with the
sniper hole-- my sketches
that I used to do
a 3D image in order
to produce a cast,
and a photograph
that I've taken in present time.
And this is the
actual sculpture.
Object from The National
Museum of Beirut--
this piece.
Objects from The
National Museum of Beirut
is inspired by inaccessibility.
And in particular, by
the inaccessibility
of the museum storage.
It dwells, by default,
on the only part
of the collection
that is visible,
the entirety of the display
on December 15, 2012.
By reproducing every captions
identifying the objects
on view, the work ironically
and vainly attempts
to represent the museum's
holdings in one image,
uncovering the politics
of historiography
and questioning the
museum as a foundation
for national identity.
The closed leather
book entitled,
Object Missing from The
National Museum of Beirut
relates to the stories heard
and unheard about the museum's
disappeared objects.
It emphasized the secrecy
surrounding their disappearance
and the inaccessibility
of pertinent information.
It triggers our imagination
in suggesting an archive that
may or may not exist.
And here you have
pinhole cameras
made out from my home
towards the museum.
And they look at
that place, which
for me has an unresolved
past, I would say.
Under-Writing Beirut-- Nahr,
the Arabic word for river,
is the second chapter
investigating the urban areas
adjacent to Beirut
River, particularly
the area named Jisr El Wati,
where I co-founded Beirut Art
Center in 2009.
The area, a historically
derelict piece of land and one
of the few remaining unexploited
space of the capitol,
has witnessed rapid
transformation
into a place of interest
for art practitioners,
and soon a high rise
residential development.
The river, which defines
the eastern edge of Beirut,
is a dry dumping ground
most of the year.
A diverse migrant
population has historically
settled along its
banks since 1915.
With the continual expansion of
the city's influx of refugees
and migrants, and
the ambitious plans
to rehabilitate the
river, the future
of the river and its
communities is unknown.
The river in this project
acts as a suspended space,
allowing me to explore notions
of borders and landscape
and to reflect on migration
and gentrification.
The drawings are based on
various maps of Beirut,
and you saw one of them earlier.
But they depart from tracing
the topography of the river
with graphite pencil.
And using wax, pastels
and dry pigments,
they evolve into more
organic abstract shapes,
reminiscent of cells,
flowers and body organs.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ENGINE HUM]
The video of the river combines
one single sequence shot
inside the dry river
with a voice over,
a poetic account on
exile and displacement.
[END PLAYBACK]
The three screen
video instillation
of After the River,
opening this afternoon,
shows the river
and its surrounding
from various angles
in an attempt
to create a multilayered
sensorial geography
of the space.
And this is a view of
After the River in Cardiff,
where it premiered.
The third chapter, which
I'm currently researching
at the Radcliffe Institute, is
entitled Under-Writing Beirut--
Ouzai.
The name Ouzai comes from the
name of a well-regarded Sunni
imam and prolific lawmaker,
Abdirahman Ouzai, I who
lived in the eighth century.
Born in Damascus and
later settling in Beirut,
the imam was renowned
for his tolerance.
He argued over 70,000 cases and
founded the main school of law
practiced in Syria and
elsewhere for centuries.
He was buried near the seaside
south of the city in a shrine.
The whole area around
his shrine became
known as the Plains of Ouzai.
Today Ouzai would be identified
as part of the Southern suburbs
of Beirut, which
are often referred
to monolithically as Dahieh,
which means suburb in Arabic.
Until the '50s,
Ouzai was no more
than a plain of sand dunes.
Today it is a complicated,
densely populated
urban landscape, full of mostly
informal constructions made
by various waves of
rural Lebanese migrants,
mostly Shiite and
other displaced
people who settled and found
refuge in the area in the '70s
and '80s.
The area has experienced
countless overlapping claims
and struggles for
land ownership.
Somehow through it
all, Ouzai seems
to resist definition,
existing inside the loopholes
and edges of legality.
So I came to be interested in
Ouzais through my feature film,
And the Living is
Easy, because one
of the character whom
I met at [INAUDIBLE]
was living in Ouzai.
And this is where I first
started filming there in 2011.
At the time of the
first settlers,
the land was known as musha, or
state-owned land property held
by municipalities or
large group of co-owners,
which all inhabitants of the
area had the right to use.
Despite this, a few families
made claims to the land in '55.
Their conflict culminated in
a formal trial, [INAUDIBLE],
which means the trials of
the dunes or of the sands,
where it was ruled that
the land would be private.
Even then, people moved in and
constructed homes informally
despite the ruling, and
sometimes in reaction
to it, against the government.
Furthermore,
properties were often
co-owned by so
many people that it
was impossible to regulate
informal settlement
on private land.
Nearby, beach resorts were
being built along the shore,
reaching the peak vacation
traffic in the '60s.
Ouzai, amidst legal
confusion and just north
of the airport built in
'54, remained less desirable
and less conventionally
buildable.
Ouzai's density
increased in 48 when
Palestinians, displaced
after the creation
of the state of Israel,
took refuge across Lebanon.
In the '70s, faced with
Israeli attacks and occupation,
residents of South Lebanon,
mostly Shia Muslim,
fled to Beirut, many settling
in the Eastern suburbs.
However, civil massacres
between Christian and Muslim
would displace those
Shiite migrants again,
causing them to resettle
in Southern Western suburbs
like Ouzai.
And amorphous in
structure and often
labeled as chaotic,
the neighborhood's
visual appearance has
become intertwined
with a stereotypical and
stigmatized identity,
the poor rural Shiite.
This image has been fought
over, suppressed, claimed
and reclaimed,
redefined, and co-opted
by sectarian interests.
Political parties, mainly
the Iranian-backed Hezbollah,
have used the narrative of
the historical oppression
of Shiites by the state,
by the Lebanese state,
to gather support and build
up a strong territorial base
in Ouzai.
Under-Writing
Beirut-- Ouzai had not
yet taken any specific
artistic form, deliberately.
But research so far
gathers maps, plans, images
and recorded personal
stories and uncovers
seams of social stigmatization,
sectarian conflict,
informality, urban planning,
superpositions of rights,
and legal exception.
This third chapter might
be the most challenging one
because the history
is intensely charged
with sociopolitical
complications and tensions
at the heart of the
situation of Lebanon.
Indeed, when researching
Ouzai's history,
one sees its uniqueness.
Yet many parallels with the
country as a whole can be made.
And the feeling of being
in a dead end situation
with no solutions prevails.
So I would like to thank you
and invite you to the opening.
There will be no
Q&A because of time.
But feel free to ask me any
question during the reception
opening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you very much.